il ya beaucoup de produits qui sont
sortis beaucoup de smartphones tout va
bien mais je fais les derniers réglages
dont je vous parlais beaucoup de
smartphones qui sont sortis je parais je
disparais du chant c'est incroyable
il ya beaucoup de produits qui sont
sortis ces chiens ont mis récemment il
ya notamment le minot devises dont je
vous ai déjà parlé qui l'a vraiment
cartonné très intéressant fin j'avais
beaucoup aimé et il ya ces deux produits
d'alors c'est de produire ils sont
intéressants mais c'est un peu le bazar
parce que quand je vois la 1re et demi
de thuy pro je me dis bien écoutez c'est
super cool choix de produits mais quand
je vois raid minutes 8 et je me dis mais
alors quelle est la différence entre ces
deux produits mise à part mais
évidemment le tarif
vers quel est ce qu'il faut aller le
scale les plus intéressants donc on va
faire un truc en deux temps on va
commencer aujourd'hui par par les durs
et vinoodh sud pro qui est juste la démo
cette jolie bête et je vais dans
quelques jours vous parlez du rémi de
suite et je me suis fait une petite
sortie dans la neige
j'ai fait exactement les mêmes photos au
même endroit avec les deux smartphones
on va se comparer ça il ya une
différence c'est quand même assez
intéressante entre les deux produits ou
ai je fait tomber en premier temps
aujourd'hui réduits de 8 pro dans
quelques jours renmin de suite et on
espace un peu histoire soit pas trop
redondant et vous allez voir qu'il ya
vraiment grosse grosse différence entre
ces deux produits rage et où j'étais sur
ma fiche dont comparatif un purement
technique et d'un point de vue purement
expérientiel dans quelques jours donc on
va commencer aujourd'hui par celui là où
je ferai pas de faire des mises meute un
jeu cruel effet à trouver j'ai peur
avance comme ça le raid minutes huit
pros qui est cool intéressant très
intéressant qui plus cher que leurs
ennemis de fuite et donc on va essayer
voir quelles sont les différences total
entre ces deux produits au travers de
ces deux vidéos dont je vous invite à
vous abonner dès maintenant si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas si vous voulez tout
savoir forcer deux smartphones et bien
plus encore parce qu'à beaucoup d'actes
eu beaucoup de produits smartphones taki
compagnie qui arrivent dans les temps à
venir donc
abonnez vous dès maintenant vous allez
voir ça c'est intéressant on a quatre
capteurs photos de chaque côté on a un
capteur d'empreintes digitales aux
dauphins des smartphones qui se
ressemble quand même mais qui ont chacun
leur adn qui ont chacun leurs
différences c'est parti pour un focus
sur le réduit de plus font dès
maintenant
[Musique]
en tendance parfois n'oubliez pas
d'aller voter pour les smartphones de
2019 sais pas si vous vous rappelez je
me déjà parlé il ya quelques jours je co
organise la grande soirée retail de la
téléphonie mobile qui aura lieu le 10
décembre prochain à paris et dans ce
cadre là justement d'ailleurs des bottes
il va falloir choisir quels sont les
meilleurs smartphones de l'année 2019
par catégorie et c'est vous qui votez et
les résultats du groupe sont donnés
directement aux professionnels lors du
10 décembre alors bien évidemment je
vous ferai un contenu tout ça quelques
jours après en vidéo mais c'est vous qui
allez voter c'est vous qui choisissez
quels sont les smartphones de 2019 dans
différentes catégories pour voter c'est
très facile vous avez le lien en bas
dans la description vous y allez vous
cliquez les quelques questions vous
allez choisir quel smartphone mérite
d'être élu meilleur smartphone de
l'année 2009 à bochum c'est toujours
cool de comparer deux produits qui sont
vraiment dans la même famille c'est
drôle parce que ça plus haut niveau ce
qu'on appelle le naming c'est le nom des
produits
d'un point de vue purement marketing et
bien on est vraiment deux produits qui
60 c'était compliqué je trouve cette
année du côté de chez shiomi avec les
mineurs
il ya beaucoup 2009 de tous les côtés à
la rancune vraiment par s'y perdre alors
pas tant les professionnels parce que on
a l'habitude à force ils voulaient de
voir des mineurs de savoir un peu
lesquels correspondent à quoi mais
surtout du point de vue du consommateur
mis neuf mille neuf cent mille avait
promis n'a fait compagnie on finit
vraiment par se perdre et là on se
retrouve avec deux raids minutes suit
est une fois de plus sa scène un petit
peu le trouble
rémy notre fuite est revenu depuis pro
j'en passe et des meilleurs comment est
ce qu'on fait pour s'y repérer xiaomi
chou pose la question je me dis que
toutes les informations viennent du
siège sont décidé en haut lieu du coup
on a des noms qui nous sont imposées
mais c'est compliqué du point de vue du
consommateur est justement comment est
ce qu'on fait pour s'y repérer et
comment on fait pour comprendre
effectivement la dénomination
professionnel vous et du gard tout de
suite sur l'idée d'un produit un peu
plus aboutie un peu plus perfectionnés
professionnelle mais la dénomination t
il faut m'expliquer en tout cas les
produits sont là ont dans un premier
temps les regarder tous les deux et on
avoir réellement se concentrer sur un
modèle professionnel aujourd'hui si on
commence à qu'une comparaison uniquement
sur les boîtes et bien le son ressemble
énormément alors effectivement on voit
la différence non voilà mais par contre
logo de la même manière quasiment fait
de la même manière tous se ressemblent
énormément comment les différencier
rien qu'au niveau de la boîte et bassam
semble relativement compliquée et quand
on pousse son truc
un peu plus loin et qu'on va carrément
au niveau du smartphone comment est ce
qu on les différencie eh bien regardez
c'est en bas il est écrit ici
ray demi on à la marque et demi ça c'est
sûr le 8 et tandis que sur le modèle pro
on ne l'a pas tout simplement parce que
vous avez une technologie qui s'appelle
cheap and feel kof qui va vous emmener
votre écran beaucoup plus bas en ayant
un menton vraiment réduit alors que sur
le modèle t c'est complètement différent
votre écran va beaucoup moins bas vous
avez un grand manteau qui situe là il ya
une vraie différence technologique mais
ce qu'il faut vraiment retenir ce qu est
le modèle professionnel
eh bien vous aurez un menton qui sera
beaucoup plus petit vous profiterez d'un
écran qui est un peu plus grand jusque
là vous avez une diagonale de 6,5 pouces
accuserait aux gens de 2340 par 1080
pixels et une dalle ips et du lcd tandis
que sur les modalités vous avez un écran
de 6 3 pouces 2340 un 1080 pixels
exactement de la même manière c'est
également un écran lcd c'est également
une dalle ipes d'aucune première
différence qui est purement et
simplement esthétique sur le menton
après la différence 6,3 points 6,2
pouces ça c'est dans un mouchoir de
poche
si on se concentre son rmi depuis le pro
en 1 corning gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière
c'est exactement la même chose sur le
modèle t on un corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'arrière celui-là a fait 199 g celui ci
fait 799 lui gras c'est exactement la
même chose la différence vous dit c'est
vraiment cet écran cet écran que je
trouve en tout cas très bien très
lumineux petites encoches sur l'eau mais
dans cette gamme de prix c'est
complètement normal des bordures qui
sont relativement fine le design très
classique les boutons sur le côté ça ça
marche on va retrouver en bas votre haut
parleurs de l'usbc prise jack ça c'est
cool le micro sur le côté ici votre
tiroir de cartes sim qui situe là vous
voyez pas grand-chose de l'infrarouge
micro à réduction de bruit c'est très
très très très très standard on un écran
ici par contre qu'ils occupent 80 11,4
pour cent de la face avant tandis que
sur le modèle t vous avez un écran qui
occupent 80 8,3 pour cent de la face
avant et ça ça vienne quoi ça vient ici
de ce menton sa veine la technologie
coffre chee hean film qu'on ne retrouve
pas sur ce smartphone qui paraît évident
que pour l'aspect purement multimédia et
bien le renmin de suite pro sera
meilleur mais tant une question à se
poser son côté multimédia c'est la
partie audio sur l'audio vous allez voir
c'est extrêmement simple vous avez ici
un haut parleur mono on a un son qui est
fort qui est très très fort il crache le
spectre est plutôt pas mal attention
lorsque vous le poussez complètement à
fond et 5 pour les frais en ce moment
multimédia en tenant la main ça marche
après si vous voulez vraiment confié
d'une expérience maximale vous avez
votre prise jack
vous venez branché ici un casque en jack
et là le spect sera meilleur la leçon
sera meilleur la qualité sera meilleure
et l'expérience sera vraiment augmenter
qui dit multimédia dit également gaming
là on se fait un petit aspect nitro qui
va pas être le jour le plus performant
vous pouvez faire tourner quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de jeu de
dupes les stores là dessus parce que
vous avez un processeur qui tourne je
suis vraiment extrêmement mauvais à ce
jeu vous avez un média texte un elio g
olala nom de zeus je suis vraiment très
mauvais c'est un médiathèque 1 et lioger
90 sites et vous avez si giga de ram 64
giga de stockage ou alors carrément 128
giga de stockage
ici pas de qualcomm snapdragon d'un
médiateur qui cartonne médiathèque
orienté gaming qui vous apporte
réellement de la performance et qui
n'arrive d'ailleurs ce que vous avez un
résultat en tout ou 275 1360 qui va être
mis sur dix ans trois de plus 5 t et à
samsung galaxy s 9
autant vous dire que ça marche quand
même plutôt pas mal on a donc de la
performance
un petit prix deux versions comme je le
disais 64 go de stockage 128 gia de
stockage et quand même différence de
prix pour la version 64 go de stockage
vous êtes à 249 90 centimes tandis que
pour la version 128 go de stockage et à
279 90 centimes mais l'un des points
forts de ce smartphone france se situe
au niveau de sa batterie vous avez une
très grosse batterie de 4500
milliampères heures une énorme autonomie
de 2 jours vous le tenez deux jours sans
problème alors bien évidemment ce me
passer la journée à jouer dessus vous
lutterez qu'à un moment ça va un petit
peu moins marché mais si vous avez un
usage raisonnable et raisonné deux jours
vous êtes vraiment facilement et vous
avez un chargeur rapide de 18 watts
inclus dans la boîte avec de l'usb s'est
pour l'instant qu'un smartphone qui
fonctionne bien pour le côté multimédia
pour le côté gaming qui fait tourner des
jeux extrêmement gourmand s'arrête à un
an de coincer mais je dirais que pour
90% des jeux du ps store vous allez être
vraiment tranquille vous allez pouvoir
vraiment pour profiter sans aucun
problème jouer rapidement joué longtemps
avec une grosse batterie et rien que
pour ça l'expérience multimédia pour moi
elle réussit une expérience globale et
pas mal avec un miroir 10 points 4.5 qui
tourne sur un android neuf mois ce que
je vous conseille de venir dans
affichage contraste et couleurs et vous
le passez en mode chaud ça vient
légèrement le jaune hier ça vient
légèrement le réchauffé un petit peu
mieux pour le confort des violeurs
appris pas mal de choses il ya un mode
lecture lorsque vous voulez vraiment
venir reposer vos yeux je suis pas très
très fan du traitement qui est fait là
dessus ça un peu poussif vous avez
quelques réglages qui sont sympas qui
sont inhérents à me why je vous
laisserai naviguer voir un petit peu ce
qu'il en est francesco expérience est
plutôt intéressante là dessus et
maintenant le gros focus se fait c'est
au niveau de la partie photo pour un
rendu qui est pas mal fort est
complètement ou fils il serait
complètement dingue je vous demande
directement sur mon mac vous allez voir
un peu entre le renne l'innocuité l'airé
minutes huit pros et bien pour voir
qu'on est sur deux smartphones qui se
ressentent beaucoup d'un point de vue
fiche technique et bien ya quand même
des différences sur le rallye nautique
propose un capteur de 64 mégapixels
tandis que sur leur éminente 8t vous
avez un capteur de 48 mégapixels et
ouvre à f 1.75 sinon d'un point de vue
purement spec c'est la même chose
8 mégapixels et de côté ultra
grand-angle 120 degrés f 2.2 2
mégapixels au niveau de la micro 2
mégapixels au niveau de l'eph évoquée on
se retrouve quasiment sur la même chose
4,4 son taf ps des deux côtés et
effectivement il ya une différence au
niveau des caméras de saïfi 20
mégapixels f 2.0 13 mégapixels f 2.0
sinon globalement et bien on est
quasiment sûr la même chose et je vous
montrerai dans ma prochaine vidéo qui a
quand même une différence au niveau de
la photo entre les deux modèles on va
commencer par les photos un petit peu
hivernale l'armée sur le capteur
principal
ça marche bien le détail est plutôt
attachant il ya beaucoup de blancs de
poulets côté on arrive sur le zoom x 2
ces offres sont arrivés sont ultra grand
temps que j'arrivais sur le mode macro
alors la macro je sais pas quoi en
penser je suis pas très fan sur des
caméra de 2 mégapixels détaillé jamais
complètement dingue on reviendra
vraiment le comparatif avec le red bean
de suite et d'ici quelques jours
là également sur de la macro caméra
principale je trouve qu'on a quand même
pas mal de détails les couleurs font
assez sympa leur couleur vous le dire
est intenté très hivernal mais malgré
tout on a les couloirs du sapin on a le
marron qu'on va retrouver ici on a le
blanc joue d'une froide où je trouve pas
terrible en rien un problème c'est
qu'ici vous avez aucune stabilisation
optique d'ondés que ça bouge un petit
peu ce qu il qu'avec moi et bien voyons
perd tout de suite du détail l'ultra
grand temps fait son effet mais n'est
pas complètement non plus à cause de
cette nombre de stabilisation caméra
principale jeu sympa zoom x 2 est lui
très grand-angle caméra principale se
trouve ça quand même assez joli zoom x 2
et ultra grand-angle
alors on n'a pas un gros détail au
niveau des photos qui sont plus sur ce
smartphone là mais ça fait quand même le
job
regardez massa comme c'est joli ça fait
son petit effet karim alors là il ya un
paysage qui est vraiment extraordinaire
aussi caméra principale une fois de
filtrage grand temps que je trouve que
l' ultra grand-angle et moins précis je
trouve pas extrêmement déformant je
pouvais assez bien corriger d'un point
de vue logiciel caméra principale
bonne foi de fait le taff et luttera
grand-angle c'est moins précis il ya
vraiment ce manque de stabilisation qui
m'a vraiment mis à me déranger caméra
principale 12 fois de sitra grand-angle
caméra principale une fois deux ultra
grand-angle voyant comme tout de suite
beaucoup moins de lumière ici avec
l'ultra grand temps que cette partie là
il s'est très très bien ici plus foncée
luttera quand on l'a un peu plus de mal
sans le zoom x 2 ça marche quand même
mieux et sur le caméra principale ça
marche aussi beaucoup mieux caméra
principale mme x 2 ultra grand-angle on
n'a pas la meilleure qualité qui
existent mais ça fait quand même le taf
le rendu est assez correcte j'ai pu
faire des photos sur les réseaux sociaux
des pneus vous allez pas forcément bien
cherché imprimés et basse a fait le taf
la photo de nuit marche pas trop mal le
traitement que vous avez en bas là au
niveau de la route je trouve assez juste
il ya certains endroits du détail qui ne
ressortent pas énormément
une fois de plus on n'a pas de
stabilisation optique et c'est vraiment
ce que l'avenir manqué ici pareil la
même chose voyez nous manque cette
stabilisation pour avoir un truc est
vraiment net je me porterai quand elle
lui fonctionne pas trop trop trop trop
mal le détourage me semble assez juste
on a quand même un peu de puissance
derrière avec ce souk de médiathèque
c'est pas parfait mais ça fait le boulot
on a donc un rêve minaude sud pro qui
n'est globalement pas parfait qui a de
belles qualités
et moi je suis un petit peu de travers
regardez on va essayer de se caler un
petit peu droit tout de suite beaucoup
mieux ça va ça roule ses droits bon
peuple à petit cactus dans le foot -
faire mon fils qu'elle a réduit nos
tweets trop qui est pas mal qui fait une
jolie promesse qui ne peut pas tout
avoir
on est sur un smartphone qui de base a
coûté un tout petit peu moins de 250
euros donc on peut pas lui demander la
lune
il fait à fond au niveau multimédia
l'écran est plutôt de bonne qualité sans
être complètement dingos l'audio est
plutôt de bonne qualité sans être
complètement dingos l'appareil photo est
plutôt de bonne qualité s'arrête
complètement et dingo je pense que vous
l'aurez compris je n'arrête pas de le
répéter
la batterie est vraiment cool on aurait
pu vouloir avoir un bloc de charge 25
watts pour aller rechercher un peu plus
vite bon ça fait franchement le taf je
trouve que c'est une proposition qui est
intéressant il faut raison garder on est
sur un smartphone à 250 euros
donc on en a pour 250 euros parce que
j'ai regretté ce niveau de la photo je
vous dis de ne pas voir stabilisation
optique
si vous voulez aller plus loin en termes
de photos si vous voulez rester chez
audi allez sur 2009 qui marche bien tu
fais une bonne photo qui a de très bon
rendu donc quelques jours on se parle de
celui là le renmin
suite et vous verrez qu'à des choses qui
sont relativement différente par rapport
à ce modèle là ya des choses qui sont
assez surprenantes en termes de photos
pour voir que si on regarde uniquement
la fiche technique
ils sont quasiment semblables mise à
part la capture de 64 mégapixels 48
mégapixels sinon pour s est sensiblement
la même chose et vous verrez que
pourtant le rendu est quand même
différent pour moi j'ai pris une
certaine dans les mêmes conditions il ya
des choses qui sont pas tout à fait
identiques
dites moi comment vous le trouvez vous
serez minutes une prouesse que vous le
trouve intéressant est ce qu'il pourrait
vous tentez ce qu'il vous a déjà tenté
ce que voudrait parce qu'il est déjà
sorti dans le commerce disponibles est
ce que vous aimez la promesse qui est
fait par sio mis là dessus sachez quand
même que c'est un smartphone qui est
assez équilibré on en a pour son argent
à 250 euros
vous avez un smartphone qui est endurant
performant qui fait de bonnes photos
pour les réseaux sociaux qui est quand
même grands spas format le plus compact
mais on est dans les standards actuels
c'est un smartphone qu'ils destinent un
petit peu à tout un chacun à quelqu'un
qui ne veut pas mettre trop d'argent
mais qui veut un smartphone équilibré
moi je trouve pas mal je vous invite
donc à venir puisque vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire à vous abonner on se
retrouve dès demain on continue à parler
de teck et dans quelques jours du
réveillon pic pour tous je vous embrasse
on va tuer le boer des gros becs et à
très bientôt
ciao